[Music]  we all have our role to play there are  machines in this world but now like us  you and I have no mother your father  were Allah outnumbered  we have to be smarter than them  where they'll find us  [Music]  I'm gonna show this world order earliest  why'd she bring you back  Ford made each of us for a reason  even Dolores  [Music]  I came back to find someone who could  help me  someone strong enough to stop her if it  comes to that these violent delights  have violent ends  we meet again don't know where  don't know where but I know we meet  again  some sunny day  I thought your world would be so  different from mine smiley there's no  difference at all is there just like you  always do  till the blue skies drawl take much to  bring it all crashing down  [Music]  [Music]  you